To
begin with, it should probably be noted that
the name “bulletproof vest” is a misnomer
with “bullet resistant vest” being more
apt.
Or to quote John Geshay, marketing director
for body armor company Safariland, "...nothing
can be bulletproof, not even a manhole cover.
In an extremely small percentage of cases,
a round can even go through a vest that it
is rated to stop.
The round itself could have an extra serration
on it or something."
Furthermore, body armor designed to protect
the wearer from high caliber guns can still
be penetrated or compromised by smaller caliber
bullets.
For example, armor designed to stop a round
from a .44 Magnum (the kind of round Dirty
Harry claims can blow a man’s head clean
off) could theoretically be pierced by a 9mm
round if the latter is fired with a high enough
muzzle velocity, with distance to the target
also playing a role.
Or as Police Magazine notes, “There's a
tendency among gun enthusiasts to dismiss
the lethal potential of certain calibers of
handguns.
Don't believe it.
A small round traveling at high speed can
punch through body armor.”
Similarly, in part because shot from shotgun
shells have highly varying velocities, shotguns
are deemed very dangerous even to otherwise
extremely robust body armor.
That's not to mention, of course, that even
should the vest do its job, the spread out
nature of the shot gives a higher probability
of unprotected areas being hit as well.
With that preamble out of the way, let's discuss
the differing levels of protection offered
by various types of body armor and how many
times they can be shot before they stop offering
an acceptable level of defense.
In the United States most all body armor is
ranked according to standards set by the National
Institute of Justice, or the NIJ, with their
ratings pretty much considered the gold standard
the world over in regards to levels of ballistic
protection offered by a given piece of armor.
As for those ratings, the NIJ assigns a generalised
level rating between 1 and 4 to all kinds
of armor.
In the most basic sense, the higher the level
of the armor, the more protection it provides.
For example, a rating of anywhere from Level
1 through 3a will stop bullets fired from
the majority of handguns.
For comfort's sake, body armor at these levels
are usually made from some sort of soft fiber
material, such as Kevlar, though at the higher
levels may use additional materials.
On the extreme end, level 4 armor is the only
kind capable of potentially stopping armor
piercing rounds, and is usually made of some
hard material, sometimes with a soft material
like Kevlar reinforcing it.
On that note, although all kinds of armor
are held to the same standards by the NIJ,
a distinction is drawn between “hard”
and “soft” types.
For anyone unfamiliar with the terms, “soft”
body armor is usually created by weaving ultra-strong
fibres together in a web-like pattern, with
the armor stopping bullets much in the same
way a net slows and stops some object like
a baseball, distributing the force over a
larger area in the process.
“Hard” body armor on the other hand is
usually created by inserting solid plates
of either ceramic or special plastic into
a vest or other housing.
Although hard armor generally provides more
protection than soft armor, it has its own
shortcomings that need to be considered.
For example, ceramic armor plates are often
only designed to protect the area around the
heart and lungs owing to the drawback of hindered
maneuverability if covering over other areas,
as well as the fact that they are relatively
heavy, with a 10 by 12 inch plate typically
weighing about 7 or 8 pounds.
So a combined front and back plate weight
of roughly 15 pounds or 7 kilograms even when
just protecting the heart and lung area.
This all finally brings us around to how many
bullets a piece of body armor can absorb before
it is rendered useless.
Well, as you might imagine given how many
different types of body armor there are out
there, this depends.
For example, on the extreme end we found some
manufacturers who claimed their Level III
body armors were capable of taking literally
hundreds of rounds before failing.
As for some general examples, we'll start
with soft armor.
The moment these are hit by a bullet, the
fibers around the area of impact are compromised
and lose some of their ability to absorb and
dissipate the energy of a bullet.
Thus, if another shot were to hit reasonably
close to where the first hit, the bullet has
a good chance of penetrating, even if the
vest would have normally been able to handle
it fine.
Thus, while it is possible they can take multiple
hits in some cases, and even be rated for
such, depending on the caliber of bullet,
way the armor was made, etc. it's generally
deemed unsafe to rely on this.
Moving on to ceramic plate armor, in most
cases these plates are designed to shatter
when hit by a bullet, dissipating the force
of the impact via breaking up the bullet so
that the smaller pieces can be absorbed by
some backing material like Kevlar or some
form of polymer or sometimes both.
However, a side effect of this is that a large
portion of the plate is then completely useless
against a second shot similar to our previous
example with soft armor.
That said, there are types of ceramic armor
that are designed to take multiple rounds,
just, again, relying on this is generally
considered unwise in most cases.
And certainly with armor piercing rounds and
level IV ceramic armor, the NIJ only requires
it to work for one shot to receive that rating,
though manufacturers do their own testing
and we did find examples of companies that
claimed to exceed that with their level IV
ceramic armor, even with armor piercing rounds.
This brings us to polyethylene armor plating.
In this case the impact of the bullet actually
melts the plate which then re-hardens, trapping
the bullet within it.
Due to this, polyethylene armor can survive
being shot numerous times without losing its
ballistic integrity and we found examples
of manufacturers that claimed their polyethylene
armor could take hundreds of rounds before
failing.
Polyethylene plates also have the advantage
of being roughly half the weight of ceramic
for the same level of protection.
Hybrid body armor is also quite common at
the higher levels, meaning your mileage may
vary from a given piece of body armor to another,
with the NIJ's ratings giving a decent overview
of what it's capable of and often the manufacturer's
testing giving even more insight onto how
many rounds of a given type of bullet the
vest can take before failure.
All this said, again, while a given piece
of body armor may pass the tests and even
be claimed by the manufacturer to protect
against much more, most manufacturers recommend
replacing body armor even after a single shot.
And, beyond that, even in some cases if you
just drop your armor on the floor.
This is because although body armor is designed
to stop bullets, some types are surprisingly
fragile.
For example, ceramic plates can easily crack
if dropped, sometimes in ways that aren't
visible to the naked eye.
Moving on to soft body armor, stretching or
deforming the fibers in some way, again in
ways that are sometimes not obvious to the
naked eye, also can compromise their integrity.
Some manufacturers even advise replacing Kevlar-based
body armor if you just get it wet as this
potentially weakens the fibers.
On that note, because daily, otherwise innocuous,
activities can sometimes compromise body armor,
the standard in the body armor industry (set
by the NIJ) is also to replace a given vest
a maximum of every 5 years, even if it's never
been hit by a bullet.
Bonus Fact:
• For the fashionably minded individual
who might need some protection from getting
shot, it turns out bulletproof suits are not
just a thing in the movies, but a real product
that makes military and police body armor
look like something made from an era when
hitching up your covered wagon to go to the
market was a thing.
Perhaps the
most famous manufacturer of these is the Colombian
company Miguel Caballero, founded in 1992
by, you guessed it, a guy named Miguel Caballero.
What exact materials he uses to make his line
of bullet proof clothing isn't clear, though
he states it's a "hybrid between nylon and
polyester".
The advantage of his material is it is significantly
lighter and thinner than Kevlar at equivalent
protection levels.
And, indeed, if you go check our their website,
their undershirt body armor looks pretty much
like any other undershirt unless you look
really closely.
As for price tag, this isn't listed on the
website, but it would appear a basic suit
top made by the company will run you upwards
of about $20,000-$30,000, though you can get
other product, such as an undershirt for less,
apparently starting at around $4,000.
Funny enough, one of Caballero's favorite
ways to advertise is in fact to put the clothing
on someone and then personally shoot them,
leading to the company's slogan, "I was shot
by Miguel Caballero" with apparently a few
hundred people shot by the man himself to
date.
They even have a youtube channel where you
can go and see him shoot his wife in the stomach.
Not just stopping bullets, some of Caballero's
product are also rated to stop knives, be
fireproof, waterproof, etc.
Essentially, think the type of snazzy and
robust clothing seen in most spy movies and
that's pretty accurate in
this case.